just going to bring you some breaking
news now concerning the actor kevin
spacey uh the cps the crown prosecution
service has today authorized criminal
charges against the 62 year old actor it
says this is for four counts of sexual
assault against three men the cps
special crime division has released a
statement that says kevin spacey has
also been charged with causing a person
to engage
in penetrative sexual activity without
consent the charges follow a review of
the evidence gathered by the
metropolitan police in its investigation
the crown prosecution service reminds
all concerned that criminal proceedings
against mr spacey are active and that he
has the right to a fair trial it is
extremely important that there should be
no reporting commentary or sharing of
information online which could in any
way prejudice these proceedings the
function of the cps is not to decide
whether a person is guilty of a criminal
offence but to make fair independent and
objective assessments about whether it
is appropriate to present charges
for a criminal court to consider the cps
assessment of any case is not in any
sense a finding or implication of guilt
or criminal conduct it is a finding of
fact which can only be made by a court
but rather an assessment of what it
might be possible to prove in a court in
court in accordance with the code for
crown prosecutors so that is the cps
authorizing
charges crime charges against kevin
spacey for four counts of sexual assault
against three men